[Music]
welcome back to science clique today the
coriolis force
in our universe objects naturally move
in a straight line at a constant speed
when an object does not experience any
force it has no reason to turn or change
speed and will therefore conserve its
motion
looking towards the future we can
suppose that one day humans will make
long journeys through space
for astronauts to survive for several
months we will certainly have to design
spaceships that simulate gravity since
our bodies are used to it on earth
one of the simplest solutions and the
most promising is the idea of a
centrifuge
a large spinning wheel in which the
centrifugal force would repel astronauts
outwards giving them a feeling of
gravity
let us first try to understand the
origin of the centrifugal force which
holds the astronaut against the edge
to do this we just need to observe the
situation from the outside
when the wheel spins it carries the
astronaut with its movement
if he takes a ball in his hand the ball
describes a circle because it is held by
the astronaut
but if the astronaut drops the ball it
is no longer subject to any force and it
will therefore conserve its motion and
move in a straight line until bouncing
off the edge
from our point of view the ball has
simply followed a straight line but for
the astronaut the ball seems to have
fallen towards the edge
he feels like there is an imaginary
force
the centrifugal force
it is important to understand that the
centrifugal force is not really a
physical force
when observed from the outside we
understand that the bull has not
undergone anything
once released it is no longer in contact
with the astronaut and it therefore
moves straight ahead
but by observing the ball while spinning
the astronaut has the impression that
there is an additional fictitious force
the centrifugal force which he invents
to explain the motion of the bull in his
frame of reference
[Music]
now imagine that the astronaut throws
the ball upwards
like before once released the ball
travels in a straight line until
reaching the edge of the wheel
but for the astronaut the ball leaves
his hand falls back down due to the
centrifugal effect but it also seems to
deviate slightly as it lands in front of
his feet
if he throws it higher the ball falls
even further
[Music]
from his point of view the centrifugal
force alone is not enough to describe
the motion of the ball
he must invent another fictitious force
which would deflect the ball as it moves
through the air the coriolis force
[Music]
to understand the coriolis force let's
look at the situation from the outside
when the wheel spins each point follows
a circle
these circles are faster when the point
is far from the center because it must
travel a greater distance
when the astronaut holds the ball in his
hand it follows one of these circles
with the appropriate speed
but when he throws the ball upwards it
gets closer to the axis of rotation
here it should move slower to follow the
wheel but since it has conserved its
initial motion the ball moves faster
than the wheel and it will therefore
edge ahead and eventually fall in front
of the astronaut
by throwing the ball upwards the
astronaut brought it closer to the axis
of rotation here the ball moves faster
than the wheel and will therefore edge
ahead which seems to deflect it from the
astronaut's viewpoint
moreover the astronaut himself
experiences the coriolis effect in his
own body
his head being closer to the center his
feet move faster he feels the spin and
risks nausea and loss of balance
if we wish to use this type of
centrifuge in the future we will
therefore have to build one large enough
so that the coriolis effect is
negligible for the passengers
[Music]
like the centrifugal force the coriolis
force appears when we observe a
situation while spinning
it can be in a centrifuge but also on a
carousel or even at the scale of our
entire planet
indeed the earth spins on itself once
every day
on its surface we are driven by its
rotation and the objects that are close
to the poles move slower than those
close to the equator
the coriolis effect hence applies at the
scale of the planet
[Music]
for instance if we launch a projectile
into the atmosphere due to the fact that
the earth rotates underneath the
trajectory it traces on the surface
appears to be curved
like the ball in the centrifuge the
projectile moves straight ahead but when
we measure it from the surface which
spins its path seems distorted
[Music]
the coriolis effect also applies to the
motion of air in the atmosphere
and explains why hurricanes spin in one
direction in the northern hemisphere and
in the opposite direction in the
southern hemisphere
the air that circulates near the equator
moves faster than the air closer to the
poles
when the winds drift away from the
equator
they conserve their initial speed and
therefore get ahead of the earth's spin
this difference of speed results in a
rotating motion explaining the direction
in which hurricanes spin
[Music]
still on earth the coriolis effect also
affects our perception of weight
the centrifugal force due to the fact
that the earth spins has the effect of
repelling us and acting against gravity
slightly reducing our weight
if the earth was spinning faster the
central fuga force would be stronger and
we would be lighter
if the planet turns slower the central
fuga force would be weaker and gravity
would feel more intense
now imagine a train running at the
equator
as the train advances towards the east
it moves in the same direction as the
earth's spin
its motion adds up to that of the
surface and overall the train moves
faster it experiences a stronger
centrifugal force and thus by moving
eastwards the train is lighter than at
rest
conversely if the train moved westwards
its speed would go against the earth's
spin
the centrifugal force would thus be
weaker for the train it would be heavier
than at rest
this strange phenomenon is called the
urdhvus effect
it is a special case of the coriolis
effect which shows us that the weight of
objects on earth depends on how they
move
to conclude the coriolis force is not a
real force
it is an inertial effect that appears
when we measure a trajectory from a
spinning point of view
when an object moves in a rotating frame
of reference it seems to undergo a force
which gradually curves its motion
studying the coriolis effect as a force
makes it possible to understand motions
in a centrifuge
ballistic trajectories in the atmosphere
the circulation of winds and hurricanes
or even the weight of an object moving
on earth
but the coriolis effect also helps
understand the vibrations of certain
molecules
the flight techniques used by certain
insects
the existence of points of stability in
the solar system and the
horseshoe-shaped orbits of certain
asteroids
we can even describe how fluids and
vortices behave within protoplanetary
disks in which new exoplanets form
and accretion disks that surround
supermassive black holes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you